european central bank vice president
victor constancio had some good news for
investors when he presented the findings
the simulation looked at a snapshot of
banking assets as of the end of 2013
at that time 25 banks were dangerously
low on capital reserves since then 12 of
those banks have recapitalized to deal
with the problem
but there are then 13 banks that still
have either to exactly apply
their restructuring downsize or they
will have to come up with ways to
increase their capital
the ecb test also simulated a global
financial crisis the result 13 european
banks would be at risk of folding in the
event of a severe meltdown those
institutions are located in eight
countries across europe they'll now have
two weeks to tell european banking
authorities how they plan to increase
their capital buffers
several countries including spain
received unexpectedly good marks spain's
economy was especially hard hit during
the housing crisis in 2008.
banks which failed the ecb's stress test
now have nine months to increase their
capital buffers